Peter Gama joining us here on Rich Eisen
show once again is he in double a yet
Peter I don't think so by the way John
Elway was a legitimate prospect he was
when I saw play I played some playing in
the New York Penn League and we can get
to 37 for Oneonta and he was really a
good player a great arm but obviously he
made relationships yes I spent time but
he was he was legitimate but he was a
Peter he was using the Yankees as
leverage against the Baltimore Colts at
the time correct when he was doing that
he was still Stanford hmm okay so he
never any but he never used the Yankees
as a threat or he were he would I mean
in time he would have but the the next
year you know still questioning still
play football so that was that so based
on LLA LLA was hopeless was a legitimate
guy I mean they're still getting around
it immediately there been a few others I
mean that that have been as well but
medium was a good baseball player
bo Jackson was a really good baseball
player so it's there have been guys with
legitimate football baseball guys is
just I mean is there's a kid a wide
receiver in Charlotte North Carolina
Blue is for Gard is a five star football
and a potential first-round pick in
baseball so I asked well why couldn't go
to college and play both sports and so
well you know the baseball coaches were
these kind of misses bats and fall
baseball out of place please I mean this
I don't want to hear this and you know
cook football coaches real spring
practice is really important no they're
not games are important yeah
what these guys play is ridiculous I
think too many of these athletes today
are so there's a so focus on one sport
or one sport only that that it really
hurts when there's athletes or potential
players so you don't think there's a
chance for a September call-up for Tebow
I'm being serious when I ask that
because everybody believes with the
state of the Mets right now that at
least putting fans in the seats would be
something that Tebow could could aid in
in September you don't think that's a
chance Peter um where's he gonna play I
just don't see it I really don't I don't
think the Mets will make it apart
they'd have terrible season but that
would be a fuss they have better players
they have real players of the mines and
to take kid Peabo I mean it's great in
the minor leagues that he's so seats but
it also says a lot about how bad that's
also saying that the Mets fan base and
broadcast partners aren't good enough to
to get people to watch Peter Gammons of
MLB Network joining me all right let's
talk about the Cubs
why did Theo Epstein essentially banish
Miguel Montero what's behind this first
of all I mean there was the outburst at
the end of the world series joe
management take that but pulling out
Jake Arrieta Jake Arrieta is not having
a good year I understand that he's a
free agent all the rest he is slow to
play but to say that it's Jake Arrieta
spoiled for ruining his record of not
throwing out based on it in an entire
season it mean it's it that's the sort
of thing teammate so I'll help you hurt
Anthony Rizzo use piston yeah on the
ESPN Radio in Chicago the next morning
and he said you know it's just a bad
teammate and you don't give it that's
not what we do and I think everybody
felt that way so I mean so could this be
a movement for a general manager to jump
start a team I mean is that part of this
as well because at this point they're
500 this is now this is now 78 games
into the season at 500 well I think it's
more of a this is what the Cubs culture
is this is the long-term view of what
this what this franchise is and they're
kind of keen to feel built there will be
times when they go through these slumps
you know frankly I think that you know
having Arrieta having a bad year
and Hendricks not fishing as well as he
did last year and now being hurt and a
lot of their young players suffering
from expectations they never had before
has caused them to be an average team
ago I think the sugar wing finished
first yes so I think however I do think
Milwaukee's much better than people
realize and it will be easy but at the
same time they can't look they can't let
some of the override the culture and and
Fonterra cross a line and I I what
didn't surprise me at all that he was
immediately released I thought that the
temptation that the Cubs front office
had was to have him go to the White
House with a few Cubs players that
wanted to go and then have function a
modicum of humor by saying you're fired
but but it made a fight against I know
it was something they were all chosen
your mother yesterday you know he was to
say nobody of the foot office way Peter
Gammons of the MOV Network that's why
he's our Honda insider the Honda insider
report here on the Rich Eisen show we
are a month away essentially from the
trade deadline and obviously as we get
closer and we see who's relevant in the
wild-card race and who isn't that would
be a lot of the market setting
conversation but is it possible that
Justin Verlander is the jewel that could
be out there on the mid-season market
Peter I just don't know if the Tigers
will be willing to pay 11 or 12 million
dollars to trade me I he could be had
but I don't think any team so it makes
it cause I think the only players um are
adjusted Wilson and Jackie Martino's are
the only players the Tigers can trade
and get anything for um you're not going
to get count bat for Verlander
not as the money he makes so 28 million
this year yeah I mean they have to pay
probably
have to pay half of it and there's a 14
million dollars for D prospect I don't
think it's going to happen in Detroit
plus they've got to figure out a way to
keep that team here they have a chance
because they don't have any position
players and their function school their
chance to be really bad for a long time
and I think they have to keep the fans
attention as much as they can the rest
of this season um I I don't I mean I
look at it I don't think as much as this
is the highest rate value will ever have
I don't think Gerrit Cole Katrina would
be the number one guy on the market I
don't click the Pirates ratings I think
the Pirates like they can contend next
year and they want Cole still two years
away from free agency so I think that
none of the top guys are sunny gray in
Oakland um Jose katana in Chicago and
maybe Kabat antics at the campus a game
out of the wild-card and I know and
they're trying to get enough and
enthusiasm to find a place and the
finances to build a ballpark if they
show up Alex Scott even though he's
going to be a pre age and they end up
finishing seven games out of the
wild-card
I mean to me how do they tell their fans
well you know we want the ballpark but
we're not in it to win and I think
that's why I don't think amber will
trade any pictures either
buta Gannett I think a very small market
except for double years as usual eleven
relievers in some utility players which
the Dodgers of course are masters of
compiling Peter Gammons joining me here
on the Rich Eisen show so when it's all
said and done tonight Cozart is going to
beat out Seager at the shortstop
position then he gets the donkey and
then Los Angeles fans are there not very
happy about this whole voting from Peter
what are you well everybody else make of
this with the old coyote I mean I'm I'm
a huge Seger band but every year there
are a few votes that you've got to go oh
wow Seeger zone beyond team the players
of voteban or or you'll get
pull out one way or another he's going
to be at the all-star game um I do think
4j kozol IV no because our to learn to
hit the way he has the heavier he's
having you know good luck I'm happy he's
in the all-star game I always think if
this is you know such a glorified
exhibition but sometimes you just feel
really happy that somebody gets rewarded
with gauging all sorry and that's other
Cozart is one of those guys I mean I
think that the resin head they scored a
lot of runs and they've had a few good
thing to the bullpen but they're not a
very good team at least it gives the
Reds fan something but I get it I mean I
get why Dodger fans are upset but
they're still gonna have you know
they're gonna have a lot of
representatives there so yeah I know and
they're also got 52 wins on the season
so far and if it wasn't for them the
story the first half might be the
Arizona Diamondbacks Peter I love chat
MIDI as always let's chat again soon
okay absolutely I want to talk about
baseball football be better prepared no
it's okay Peter but by the next time we
chat in July uh you know Tebow will be
triple-a by then so it's okay I'm sure
that story's not going down that way
maybe so take care of Peter that's Peter
Gammons of the MLB Network joining us
here in the Honda inside a report the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on radio stations across the country and
audience if you like that please
download our app there's lots of fun
things there other than just more of the
videos you just saw you can call us from
the app you can email us from the app
just download it trust me you'll enjoy